hi me
you are serving up another looks like
last night the vmas look at you tonight
who are you wearing this evening i am
wearing christian cowan i wish i could
have took him here with me but
unfortunately he couldn't come in oh no
what happened covet girl you know it's
limited oh my gosh honey will you look
exquisite this is your first met gal i
first met gala again are you feeling a
little nervous i'm very nervous
honey the worst thing about this event
the staircase and you're a third of the
way there thank you what is the most
difficult thing about your look this
evening my cape which represents the
black american heritage flag in the
filipino flag
this cape is really heavy
yes oh my gosh and how many people did
it take to get you ready tonight about
eight people and i have 10 million
crystals on me right now no you do not
well honey you are sparkling just as
bright as all those crystals put
together you look fantastic have fun
tonight are you looking forward to
seeing this evening all the girls
because we served you sure did
um
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
good to see you
look down the stairs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you